The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So my name
is Hari Balakrishnan,
and I'm going to take you
through the rest of 6.02,
doing the remaining
lectures in the class.
So far in 6.02,
what we've looked at
are ways in which we design
a single communication link.
So we know how to take
two computers or two nodes
and design what a link
between them might look like.
And this link might be
an actual wired link.
Or it might be a radio link.
Or it might be an acoustic link.
There's some medium over which
these two guys communicate.
And the main ideas
we've looked at
have to do with coding,
in particular, channel
coding, which is a strategy to
combat noise and errors that
might show up on the channel.
And then in order to
match what we communicate
to the characteristics of
the channel-- for example,
the ability of the channel
to deal in sinusoids--
we studied modulation
and de-modulation.
So those are the two main
elements that we studied.
And in both of these, we
looked at both how you do this
to achieve reliability--
because ultimately,
we want to communicate
information in a way
that's reliable--
and do it efficiently.
In particular with
modulation, we
look at a scheme
to share a medium
amongst multiple conversations,
frequency division
multiplexing, which
is the topic of one
of the tasks on this lab.
And with coding,
we looked at ways
in which you do this coding in a
way that isn't just replicating
every bit but involves some
linear algebra operations that
allows you to gain efficiency.
So the rest of the
class is really
about taking for
granted our ability
to design communication
links and putting them
together and composing
them to build networks.
So the basic problem is
actually very, very easy.
The problem is, you're
given a set of nodes--
let's say computers-- and
the problem you want to solve
is to come up with
a way by which you
can allow any
computer or any phone
or any device on this
network to communicate
with any other device
on the network.
And that's the problem.
So you're given n nodes.
And you want all-to-all
communication.
Now, this is a little
different from the kind
of-- there are other
networks you could design.
You could design a network
where you're given n nodes
and you have 1 to
n communication.
There's one transmitter,
many, many receivers,
and you want to design a
network for that purpose.
What's an example
of a network where
you have one transmitter,
many receivers,
and you just want to build
something that makes that work?
Radio is one example.
Television is another example.
And those are good examples.
In fact, for those kinds
of one-to-many networks
whether you have--
or k to n networks
where you have k sources of
information and n receivers
and k is a lot
smaller than n, it'll
turn out that the basic
frequency division
approach makes sense.
I mean, that's how radio
stations or TV stations work.
Someone in the US-- the Federal
Communications Commission
has decided to allocate
different chunks of frequency
to different TV stations and
different radio stations.
And the assumption is they're
always going to be using it.
Turns out that assumption
may or may not be true.
But under the assumption
that they're always
going to be using
it and you have
many, many, many
receivers, you just
divide up frequencies and
allow them each to transmit
in their own frequencies.
And then you have
a receiver that's
capable of tuning to
different frequencies.
And you get the information
or the channel that you want.
We'll actually come
back to that problem
a little bit in the
next two lectures.
But for today, the design
problem-- and going forward,
the design problem you
should have in mind
is you want a network where you
have all-to-all communication
and you want to be able to
support any application.
This is a big deal.
We're not just
designing a network
to allow telephone
calls to work.
Or we're not just designing
a network that allows
you to do video conferencing.
We're trying to
design a network where
any application can run on it--
in particular, applications that
you might not have envisioned.
This is the reason why the
internet works really well
is because when they
designed the internet,
they designed it under
some set of assumptions.
But they were
really, really smart
to design a network that
made minimal assumptions
about the application.
So it's a network
that's good enough
for almost any application,
though it isn't perfectly
optimal for any application.
It's just good enough
for everything.
And that's a really
good characteristic
of a well-designed
network is if it
can work even for things
you didn't even dream of.
When they build the
internet, they suddenly
didn't dream that
the web would exist.
They didn't dream that people
would be tweeting and telling
people they're going
to the bathroom
or whatever they do on Twitter.
I mean, they designed a network.
And it just kind of is amazing
that all these applications
can work.
So the question is, what
did they do correct?
What did they do right?
And what are things that--
what general lessons
can we learn from it?
And the general
high level lessons
you learn actually apply
to any system you build.
It'll turn out that
whenever-- if you're
confronted with a real
world problem in an industry
or research or
whatever, very often
you're trying to make decisions
on what you need to be doing.
And it's very tempting
to make decisions
based on what you think
it's going to be used for.
But very often, what you end
up eventually using it for
is very different from what
you thought in the beginning.
So it's good to have
applications in mind.
But it's good not to embed too
much about those applications
in the design of network.
So the high-level
principle here is
how you can do
something that works
well enough without making too
many assumptions about what's
running on top of it.
There are two big themes.
They're the same two themes that
we studied before that we're
going to keep coming back to.
The first is efficiency.
And the second is reliability.
The same two themes we come
back to over and over again.
There's a third important theme
about network design, which
has to do with scalability.
I mean, how can you make
it work so this network can
work for millions or
billions of devices
and billions of computers?
That's a topic we're not
really going to talk about.
I'll get to it in
the last lecture.
But 6.033 and 6.829 we'll
talk about those issues.
So let me start first
with efficiency.
If I tell you how to build
a communication link that
can communicate between any two
devices or any two computers,
it should be pretty
straightforward to now design
a network that allows
all-to-all communication.
Something out?
That's a mouse.
Great.
One way you can
design this network
is to simply take your
communication link that we
know how to build and do this.
Just connect every
pair of computers
or every pair of
nodes to each other.
I'm probably missing
a few of these.
But this is a great
network design
because it's composed of bunch
of links to build a network.
So why don't we do this?
Or maybe we should do this.
What?
It's too expensive.
Why is it too expensive?
Sorry?
You know, how many of you
are in Professor [INAUDIBLE]
recitation?
Great.
I understand he gives
you guys money to answer
or if he makes a mistake.
I'm going to do the same thing.
Whenever I make a mistake,
Professor [INAUDIBLE]
will give you some money.
[LAUGHTER]
So I actually-- I mean,
don't hold me to this.
But why don't you guys answer?
This is pretty straightforward.
How many links do you need?
n [? choose ?] 2.
It's about n squared, right?
So n squared, depending
on the context,
it's either too
big or too small.
But it's about n2 to
n squared lengths.
It turns out that's actually a
pretty large number of links,
because--
and the notes talk about
some of the reasons
why this is too expensive.
But the other reason
it's a problem
is that it's one thing
to design a network where
every computer in this room
can talk to each other.
And conceivably, we might get
tangled up in all these wires.
But we could
imagine laying wires
between every pair of our
computers and communicating.
But there are two reasons
this is a big problem.
I want to communicate with
computers in California
or China or wherever.
And individual links
going across the world
and my computer to
China and your computer
to another computer in
China just doesn't scale.
It doesn't work very well.
And the second problem, the
reason why this issue matters
is that not all communication
links are wires.
In fact, right now, the most
dominant mode by which people
gain access to the
internet, including
right now in this
room, is through radio,
is through wireless.
And this is a shared medium.
So it's not like we can somehow
put these wires together.
We're going to have to share
this communication medium.
this communication network.
And somehow we have to
come up with a strategy
to do this efficiently.
There's a few different
principles involved
in how you design networks.
But the main one
is that we're going
to construct a special
computer called a switch.
And a lot of what
we're going to be doing
has to do with what
we do in the switch.
The other part of what
we're going to be doing
is what we do in the
computers itself.
So our network is
going to be designed
using a set of rules that
are obeyed and implemented
and followed by the computers.
OK, a special set of
rules that are implemented
by these computers called
switches and a special set
of rules that are implemented
by the end computers,
by the devices on the network.
And together, they're going to
make our communication work.
So the high level
plan is going to be
that we take these computers
and rather than put wires
between every pair
of them, we're
going to connect
them together into--
perhaps there's lots and lots
of computers and many of them
get connected to one of these
boxes, which is a switch.
And a switch may connect
to other switches.
And some of these switches
may have other computers
attached to them.
And then eventually you might
get to other end computers.
And when you build
a network like this,
a structure like this,
this kind of a picture
is called the network topology.
A switch has one or more
links attached to it.
These links could be wires.
They could be
shared things like--
like this thing
here is a switch.
It has no visible
links, but it probably
has one wire link
connecting it via ethernet
to the rest of the MIT campus.
And out here lots of computers
right now are connected to it.
It gives the illusion that
each of your computers
has a separate
link to the switch.
And we look at how that
illusion is maintained and done
next time, next lecture.
But this is an example of a
switch, probably the world's--
you know, this thing is
made, I think, by Cisco.
So they charge $600
or $800 for it.
But really, you
can buy it for $40.
When you put the word
"enterprise" next to anything
you sell, you can
mark up the price.
But anyway, the world's
cheapest switches
are on Wi-Fi access points.
So you connect the stuff
together into a topology.
And the job of the
switch is to look
at messages that come
in from these links
and figure out what to
do with those messages
and make sure that together
they coordinate to get messages
to the destinations to which
you wish to send those messages.
So here's a picture
that I got today
from MIT's ISNT, which is
a picture of MIT'S network.
So I just want to give you
a sense for what this looks
like for a campus like MIT.
So the first thing to notice
is that this is actually--
it's got some
redundancy built in.
You don't see it in the picture.
But really what's going
on here is that we
have these two routers here.
In the context of the
internet, these switches
are also called routers.
It's taken me 10
years to pronounce
it router because
where I was brought up,
they pronounced it "rooter."
And many people say that.
But in the US,
they say "router."
So anyway, these routers here,
there are two backbone routers.
And they're actually-- each of
these guys, these other routers
in these different buildings,
are connected, actually,
to both of these.
So the idea here is that if
one of those links were to fail
or if one of these
routers were to fail,
the other guy would take
over and handle this traffic.
Under normal
conditions traffic is
kind of balanced between
these two different routers.
So some of these computers--
some of these other routers
are connected to one of them.
Some of the other routers
are connected to the other.
And together they work
to provide connectivity.
These backbone
routers get connected
to these things that are
called external routers, which
are routers that connect
to various other networks
and internet service
providers that MIT uses.
MIT is extremely well connected.
The amount of bandwidth
coming in and out,
as you might have noticed
doing, I don't know, bittorent
or whatever the cool people
do these days with networks,
is phenomenal.
MIT commercially uses Sprint,
which is an internet service
provider, uses
level three, which
is probably the biggest internet
service provider in the US.
This thing called
[INAUDIBLE] tech is--
I found is that-- so
MIT now does telephony
through the internet.
So it's voice over IP as opposed
to the old telephone system.
So a lot of that voice traffic
goes through that network
service provider.
Other things here--
this NOX is--
I think it stands for
the Northeast Crossroads
or something like that.
It connects to a network
called the internet
two, which is a network
connecting many universities
in the US.
And it's a very, very
high bandwidth network.
And so if you were
to communicate
with, say, a Stanford
or something like that,
it wouldn't go over
the public internet.
It goes over a network
that's essentially not
commercially paid for
but is a private network
connecting different
universities.
And it has a
connection to Comcast.
So many people who have Comcast
in their homes in this area
tend to have good--
or are supposed
to, in theory, have
good delay, low delay to MIT.
Out here on this side, MIT is
connected to other research
and education networks.
It has high
connectivity to fermilab
and to [INAUDIBLE],,
because I'm assuming
there's a huge amount of data
flowing because of things
like the LFC experiments.
They send terabytes or petabytes
of data back and forth.
So you need high bandwidth.
So they have their own
network connection to do that.
This NLR is something called
the National Lambda Rail, which
is another high speed network
connecting a bunch of East
Coast universities.
And then out here
on the edges, you
have MIT connecting to other--
out here-- other internet
service providers.
This thing here is funny.
It's called Big Ape,
which is actually--
its called the Big
Apple peering exchange.
It's this place in New York City
where a lot of people-- a lot
of companies and internet
service providers
have gotten together.
And you can just connect
to other networks.
So MIT connects to, I
think, 13 other networks
on a non-payment basis.
Whereas to internet
service providers
you have to pay money, you
can peer with other networks
essentially on a
bilateral agreement.
So I carry your traffic,
you carry my traffic.
So it turns out that
out in New York,
there is this building where a
lot of these different networks
have gotten together.
And MIT is one among
those networks.
So it has extremely
good connectivity.
But you can see that already
MIT is a tiny campus.
And already it's got
such rich connectivity
to the rest of the internet.
I guess as far as college
campuses go, it's a big campus.
But still, in the grand
scale of the internet,
it's a tiny thing.
And you can already
see that there's
so much complexity and
so many things going on
inside the network.
So the question is, how does
this network get designed?
And the main idea that
I want to get at today
is this idea of packets
and packet switching.
So the design principle that's
used in communication networks
is this idea of packets
and packet switching.
There are some special
rules-- simple,
special rules that
you have to follow
to allow these switches to
send messages back and forth.
And in fact, these are
fairly obvious rules.
But what's remarkable about
them is how simple they are.
And they can work.
The main idea is that
you take your message
and you have to decide who
it needs to be sent to.
And you have to decide
who it's coming from.
So if I decide that I want
to send a message to you
in this network, my
computer and your computer
have to somehow have names
associated with them.
And in the context of packet
switched networks, these names
that we associate with--
ideally, these names should
be associated with computers.
But they turn out
to be names that
are associated with the link
that you use from your computer
to send these messages.
These names are
called addresses.
So very concretely, if
I have a computer here,
my computer may have a name.
But this computer here has
two or three different links
coming out of it.
If I connect this--
even this thing here or this
ethernet link to the USB port
here and I connect a cable
to it, that's one link.
The Wi-Fi on this
is another link.
If I turn the Bluetooth on and
use that, it's a third link.
Each of those links
has a different name.
The name here is
equivalent to an address.
Each of these things
is an address.
So when I send a packet, I
have to tell you my address.
And similarly, if I want
to send someone else,
some other computer,
a packet, I have
to specify the address
that I wish to send it to.
So that's the first rule
of packet switching.
It's specify an address--
in particular, specify
a destination address.
And you specify
a source address.
Now, the idea is once
I specify the addresses
and I construct a message, my
message has some bits in it.
Maybe it's a file.
Maybe it's a piece
of video or whatever.
I add something to that message,
which I call the header.
The header has a bunch of fields
in it specifying something
about what should be
done with the message.
But the only two
important things here--
there's three or four
things that you need.
But the non-negotiable part
that you need is a part of this
address--
part of this header should
specify the destination
address.
There's other parts of it that
specify the source address,
as well.
The basic structure
is very simple.
I send a message in which I
specify a destination address.
And the job-- and my job is
done as the source for the time
being.
I send it to some switch.
I'm connected to a
bunch of switches.
My computer picks a
switch to send it to.
The switch it picks is
typically the switch
that that link is connected to.
So if I am connected right now
through ethernet and Wi-Fi,
there's some rule
on my computer that
decides whether to
use ethernet or Wi-Fi.
And let's say it
decides to use Wi-Fi.
It sends this
thing, this message,
with this destination
address to that access point.
And that's the first
switch it goes to.
And then it becomes
the switch's job
to figure out how
to get this message
to the actual destination.
This combination of a header
that includes the destination
address and some
number of bits that
corresponds to the message,
this entire bag of bits
is called a packet.
For something technically
to be considered a packet,
it needs to have
an address on it.
Or it needs to have
something that's
equivalent to an address
on it that then allows
the rest of the
network to decide
how to send that packet onward.
This is a lot like the
way the post office works.
When you deliver--
you write your letter.
You write who it's from.
And you write who it's to.
You put it in the mailbox.
Your job is done.
And maybe at some later point,
if it's registered post,
you get an acknowledgment
that the other guy
received the message.
Packet switch networks
are very much like that.
They just work a
little bit faster.
Now, why is this idea good?
Now, the reason
this idea is good
is that it's extremely robust at
dealing with failures, at least
in theory, because it becomes
the job of the switches
and the network to
talk to each other
and run some sort of
algorithm between each other
that allows them to always
construct and maintain
some information that allows
them to always, no matter what
the failures are, as long as
there is some path that takes
you from here to there in the
network, regardless of failure,
as long as the underlying
topology allows you
at least one path to get
between one place to another,
the switches figure that out.
And if you want to make
a network more reliable,
you add more switches
and more links.
And you figure out how
to make it reliable.
The end points and nothing
else have to really bother
with that problem.
And you can take portions of
the network that are unreliable
and add some redundancy to
it, add more pads to it,
and run some other
algorithm that
allows the switches
to figure out
how to divert, how
to route packets,
or how to move these
messages across.
And this idea is
a brilliant idea.
It looks completely
obvious in retrospect,
like all brilliant ideas.
But it's actually quite recent.
I think they celebrated its
50th anniversary quite recently.
In 1959, Paul Baran, who
was at the RAND Corporation
at the time, wrote one or two--
you know, it's not often you
can call a paper seminal.
This is seminal.
This is really important.
It just changed the way
communication worked.
His paper is called on
distributed communications,
introduction to--
the first one was "Introduction
to Distributed Communication
Networks," where he looked at
various ways you could design
these network topologies and
completely theoretically argued
that this design would allow
you to build a network that
could withstand various
kinds of failures--
in particular, even
adversarial failures caused
by enemy attacks.
And the second part of the
story with these messages that
are in packets is
he said that if I
want to communicate a
large amount of data,
what you should do is break
it up into smaller pieces.
So you take a message-- if you
have a big file to transfer,
don't put it in one big packet.
But instead, you break
it up into smaller pieces
and send each piece
into the network.
So a big file gets broken
up into many packets.
Each packet becomes an
independent, atomic unit
of delivery.
Packets could be sent
along very different paths,
in principle, between
any point in the network
and any other point
in the network.
And at the other end,
packets could arrive along
different paths.
And as long as there's
some working path,
it's the job of the
network to figure out how
to get those packets through.
That's the basic idea.
So the first one is this idea
of using an address on messages.
The second one is the idea of
breaking it up into packets.
And in particular, these packets
could all take arbitrary paths.
The sources and the destinations
don't determine the path.
The switches determine the
paths that you have to use,
using some algorithms that
we're going to be studying.
So is the idea clear?
Does everybody
understand kind of what
a packet switched network is?
The textbook-- the
notes also talk
about other ways of doing it.
The other big way of doing
it, which predates this,
was what was done in the
Bell Telephone network.
It's called circuit switching.
It's a different idea.
I'm not going to talk
about in lecture.
You can read about it.
It's important stuff to
read about, but mostly
cultural at this point,
because almost every network is
packet switched today.
So any questions
about this idea?
It's pretty simple.
OK.
So here's an example of the
world's simplest packet header.
This is the 6.02
reference design.
So for the labs and
everything else,
this is the packet header
we're going to be using.
It has just four fields--
a destination address,
which specifies where
the packets should be sent.
It has something called
the hop limit, which
I will talk about in
a couple of lectures
from now as to why we need it.
It has a source address,
mainly because when
I receive a message--
when this computer receives
a message from someone,
it often wants to send a
message back in response.
And having the
source address allows
it to send a message back to
the person who sent the message.
It's just for two
way communication.
And it has a length.
And the reason for having
the length is convenience.
You kind of know once
the header is done,
how many bits do you need?
Or how big is the actual data
corresponding to the packet?
It's also called the payload.
How big is the
payload in the packet?
Now, real world packet header
is a little more complicated.
Just for concreteness,
this is what
IP version 6, which
is the version
of IP everybody's trying to
move to, the internet protocol,
looks like.
It has the destination
and source addresses.
It has the hop limit.
It has the length.
And it's got a few other
things that we're not
going to worry about.
They have to do with
allowing switches
to prioritize certain
kinds of packets so that--
I guess things like if you were
doing Skype or voice telephony,
you might want to schedule
those packets differently
in the switch so
you get low delay.
Or if you were--
maybe the CEO's packets get
higher priority, whatever.
You could come up with
policies on deciding
how you switch these--
how you schedule these packets.
So that's the main idea
in packet switching.
For the rest of
today, I actually
want to talk about two
performance metrics
that people use to evaluate
how well a packet switching
network is doing in terms of
how properties that users care
about.
And I want to also explain
to you why this idea works--
like, this idea that
nodes just send data.
All these nodes are sharing
a communication medium--
I'm sorry.
Sharing resources in the switch.
So this node can send packets.
This node can send packets.
And the switch must
have a plan in mind to--
let's say that all these packets
are going to some destination
and have to go on this link.
This switch must
have a plan in mind
for deciding how to take
all these packets that
are coming in and sending
them along this link.
I mean, for example, what
happens if packets come too
fast for the switch to handle?
The speed of these links when
they all simultaneously send
packets could be
bigger than the speed
of the link going this way.
What does the
switch do with that?
Does it just drop the packets?
Does it hold onto
them for some time?
What does it actually do?
And I want to do this first
with a very simple picture that
tries to get at why this idea
really, really actually works.
This idea that makes
packet switching work
has a fancy name.
It's called statistical
multiplexing.
So let me explain
what that means.
Let's take it with a
very simple picture.
So let's say that you have a
switch with one link coming out
of it.
And let's say that the
speed of this link--
I need to get into
some metrics here.
So links are measured in
terms of how quickly--
how quickly is the wrong word.
In terms of the rate at
which they can send data.
And there's another metric,
which is the delay of the link.
So I'll get to both of these
more carefully in a bit.
But the important thing right
now I want to keep in mind
is the rate of the link.
This is the rate at which
it can send bits per second.
It's a measure of throughput.
So it's typically measured
in bits per second.
So let me actually imagine
that the rate of this link
is one megabyte
per second, which
is 10 to the 6, which is a
million bytes per second,
or about 10 million
bits per second.
Let's imagine a simple
network that looks like this.
Let's imagine that all
these links are also coming
in at 1 megabyte per second.
If somebody came
and told you, here's
the design of my network.
I have a switch.
It's connected to three
computers, each of which can--
is connected with a
link whose maximum speed
is one megabyte per second.
And this switch is going
to connect to something
else downstream,
maybe another switch,
and it goes somewhere else.
And the speed of this link
is one megabyte per second.
Is this a good network design?
How would you go about
assessing that question?
Is this good or bad?
How would you know?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
So let me ask this before
we answer this question.
Let's say this was 10
megabytes per second.
Is this a good network design?
It is.
You're paying too
much, though, because I
mean, really, this
link is too fast
for the amount of load
that is coming in.
But yeah, you know, it's a
reasonable network design.
But the real question
is, if it's one here,
is it a good network design?
And the answer, as the
gentleman here pointed out,
is it really depends
on how much traffic
or how many packets
per second or bits
per second these
different computers
are going to be sending.
Let's say that they
all actually send--
when they send
traffic, they send
at one megabyte per second.
And when they don't send
traffic, they're quiet.
How would you determine whether
this is a good network design,
whether this works or not?
Like, in practice,
on average, how often
can each of these
guys be sending
before you determine
that this is probably
not-- this network
isn't going to work.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
And they may or
may not be equal.
Ideally, what you'd like
is just to make sure
that over some
window of time, they
sent slower than the rate
at which this link can
ship packets.
Now, the reason why
packet switching works
is that when you build
a network like this
and you scan it out
to bigger numbers,
it turns out to be extremely
unlikely that everybody
using the network exercises
the network at exactly
the same time.
I mean, a bunch of people
might have their computer on.
But if you think about how
it's used, you click on a link
and you get a bunch
of stuff showing up.
And then you click on--
you read it for some time.
You click on a link and
something else shows up.
Or if you're watching a video
stream, video is compressed.
So if the scene
changes very often,
you end up using a
lot more of the--
in terms of the bitrate.
But then every once
in a while, it's
one of these old Russian
movies where nothing's
changing for 10 minutes.
And it's very
heavily compressed.
And then you get
to Schwarzenegger
and it's blowing
your bandwidth limit.
So I mean, it's
kind of like that.
Traffic is bursty.
So when traffic
arrives in bursts
and the users are not all highly
correlated with each other--
I mean, from time to time,
you do get these correlations.
These are called flash crowds.
Presumably this
happened last night.
Everybody is hitting refresh
on the New York Times website.
And presumably what's
happening there, of course,
is that these websites really
know what they're doing.
So they've actually provisioned
with the expectation
that starting from
8:00 PM, everybody
is sitting there glued.
Nothing's changing, but
everybody's hitting reload.
And they've designed
this network--
they've provisioned
their network
to allow for people to
get the answers they want
or the results they want to see.
So here's some pictures.
So what I did was I took--
I sniffed on the
traffic in this room.
So here's the kind of
stuff that you see.
So this is the traffic in
this room during lecture.
Now, this is actually
not this semester.
But I would assume that
it's fairly typical.
I should also say this
was during-- well,
I don't want to say.
The x-axis in these
pictures is time.
The y-axis is the number
of bytes that was sent.
So you can see that
what I've done on top
is I've broken time into
10 millisecond windows.
So initially on top, it's
every 10 milliseconds I just
count the total number of bits--
actually, total number of bytes
that was sent.
Now, you can't read the
scale on the y-axis on top.
But on the top curve, it goes up
to 200,000 bytes in a small 10
millisecond window.
Then the curve down here
does the same thing.
But I've picked 100
millisecond window.
Now you can see that what
has happened when you've
picked a bigger window of time?
Has it become smoother
or less smoother?
What can you say about it?
It's become a little smoother.
But surely there
still are these peaks.
The bursts do become smoother.
But they don't
completely disappear.
And what's remarkable
about network traffic
is that these bursts never
completely disappear,
but they do get a little
smoother as you aggregate over
more time.
Over 100 millisecond windows,
that's what it looks like.
Over one second window,
it looks smoother.
But you can actually see
that from time to time,
there are these big bursts
that take up a lot of the--
that end up over any window
of time that you expand out,
there's still some
probability with which
you'll see a big
burst of traffic
showing up in that window.
That's kind of a nice and
noteworthy characteristic
of kind of real
world data traffic.
In fact, even when you go to
10 second windows, it says,
look, I'm looking at
10 seconds at a time.
You get stuff that
looks like this.
MIT runs a website
you can get access
to using your web certificates.
It's called mrtg.mit.edu.
You can actually
go to this website
and you can see, for
different switches,
including ones in
your dorm or wherever
you're living if
you live on campus,
you can actually look at the
statistics from your router.
They do this on a
per switch level.
It's kind of interesting to see
when people use this network
and when they don't.
I think an interesting
characteristic
of MIT's networks
is it turns out
if you look at some of
the dawn network traffic,
it peaks at between 1:00
and 3:00 or 1:00 and 4:00
in the morning, which
is probably good,
because honestly, I think
MIT should negotiate
preferential pricing
with ISPs, because no one
else is using those ISP
networks at that time.
So it would be actually--
it turns out I learned that
the Amazon Kindle kind of does
that.
When you do your
newspaper subscriptions,
they actually send it
through wireless networks,
through this commercial 3G
and 4G wireless networks.
And I believe that
what they do is
they send it to you in
the middle of the night
when not many people
other than at MIT
are using those networks.
So you could take advantage
of some of these time
varying properties
[INAUDIBLE] doing it.
So why did I tell
you this story?
The same thing-- I showed
you these time windows.
The same thing applies when
you bring many, many users
together.
The odds that we all
are going to click
on some link at exactly
the same time and all of us
cause a burst of traffic to
happen exactly at the same time
is extremely small.
Now, it can happen if there's
an adversary in the network.
If there are bad
guys-- and how many of
you have heard of denial
of service attacks?
Yeah, DDoS, Distributed
Denial of Service attacks.
I understand if you know Russian
you get an edge in doing it.
So these things are
launched because they
commandeer a whole
bunch of machines
and they coordinate an attack.
They destroy the
assumptions that
make statistical
multiplexing work
because the normal
assumption is people
are not exercising the
network at the same time.
So you're not attacking
some website or whatever
at the same time.
But if you coordinate
an attack, then you
make that assumption not hold,
causing congestion to happen,
causing traffic to exceed what
your network link can support.
But under normal,
non-adversarial conditions,
the assumption is that people
are randomly gaining access
to the network, which means
that you can actually get away
with the design of a network
that looks like this as
long as you study statistics
like the average amount
of traffic.
Like, on average,
the guy is not going
to be sending more
than-- this node is not
going to be sending more than
a certain amount of traffic
when measured over
some period of time.
What happens when people
send traffic in a burst?
What happens when,
from time to time,
in fact, you see these
bursts of traffic, right?
You look at this picture here.
You do it over a one
second window or a 100
millisecond window and you see
these big peaks of traffic.
Lots of bytes at 100
millisecond window.
What that really means
is that this switch here
is going to be getting
traffic from different users
that probably exceeds--
you know, is perhaps the sum
of all of the input links.
So it's a large
amount of traffic.
If you have a design like
this, something's got to give,
because you're getting
water or packets
coming in at one megabyte
per second times three.
And you've got a
link that can only
send one megabyte per second.
So what can you do?
What can the switch do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The easiest thing
it can do is just drop it.
Just say, you know what?
Just drop it.
You laugh, but I'm telling
you, sometimes dropping it
and letting the end
point deal with it
is a better strategy
than holding onto it
and simply keeping it in line.
It's like, you've got
to be careful, right?
I like the idea of storing it.
But for how long
do you store it?
How much do you store?
For example, if I look at
that burst of traffic here
and I have a network
like this and I
look at this big
burst of traffic
here, over a 10
second window, I'm
seeing traffic that's probably,
in this example, perhaps
10 or 100 times bigger
than the average.
The average is sitting
down somewhere.
And maybe this is 10
times the average.
The peak to average ratio
might be 10 to 1 or 20 to 1.
So how much should you
store inside the switch?
If you were designing
a network and I
told you, well, all
right, good idea.
Why don't you store the packets.
You're going to put these
packets into a data structure
called a queue, right?
Packets come in.
Packets go out.
Packets go out whenever the
link is able to send packets.
You keep shipping packets out.
In the meantime,
traffic's coming
faster than you can handle.
You're going to put
stuff in a queue.
How much?
Do you want to keep everything?
If you did, you'd be
like Disney World,
because they have these
lines that go forever,
and nothing's
moving and everybody
just piles on the
end of the line.
This is a tough question.
We're going to answer
this question somewhat.
There's no single, easy
answer to this question.
But the rule of thumb that I'm
going to have you keep in mind
now is you're probably going
to keep between 10 milliseconds
and 100 milliseconds
worth of traffic.
I'll get to why later.
For now, it's some small
amount of time worth--
amount of traffic.
The reason why you
need this queue
is to absorb a burst of
traffic that you're not
able to immediately send.
But the important principle
in a packet switch network
is, you need a queue, but
they're a necessary evil,
because the only thing that
the queue is doing for you
is absorbing the burst.
But the only thing-- the bad
thing that it's doing for you
is adding delay.
Just because you have
a queue, the network
ain't going to move faster.
The network's moving-- the
link's moving at the same speed
whether you have a queue or not.
The only thing the queue is
doing is it absorbs a burst
so that whenever the network
link is able to send packets,
you can ship packets
from the queue
and you don't want to
drop too many packets.
Now, if you're lucky,
the size of the queue
is enough to absorb
all of the burst.
And then the traffic eases
and you get to send the rest.
But if you're unlucky,
the queue overflows
and you drop some packets.
And then the endpoints have
to somehow deal with it.
So what are the things
we've looked at?
Packet switch
networks as defined
by a header, which includes
the destination address.
The way the network works
is that the sources just
ship a packet with the header
that includes the destination
address.
The switches somehow are going
to figure out how to ship--
how to get those packets
to the destination.
The reason why
this stuff works is
because of the
statistical multiplexing.
And finally, the reason we
need a queue in a packet switch
network is to
absorb these bursts.
So what I want to do in the
remaining six or seven minutes
is to tell you about the
other metric by which we're
going to evaluate our networks.
The first metric I introduced
already is the rate of a link.
When you have links
of different rates,
you can also define the rate
for an actual communication.
When a source sends a
packet to a destination,
you can measure the
rate at which bits are
arriving at the destination.
That's the throughput of the
data transfer of the bit rate.
The other metric we're
going to care a lot about
is called the delay.
The fancy term for
delay is latency.
I really don't know why
they have two terms.
But you know, from
time to time, people
use the word delay or latency.
And by the way, I'm going to try
hard to use the word rate here
or bitrate or throughput.
Often you see the word
bandwidth, like oh,
my bandwidth is 10
megabits per second.
And that's actually
fine to use, except it's
confusing in a real
communication system
because we're going to--
we've already used
the word bandwidth
to refer to a frequency.
And so we've already
said the bandwidth
is defined in terms of, say,
Hertz or something like that.
And it's just a little confusing
to also use bandwidth for rate.
So we're going to
try to use words
like bitrate and throughput
to refer to bits per second.
So delay is measured in
seconds or milliseconds
or microseconds.
And what we want is you
have a source that sends
a packet or set of packets--
let's say a single packet
to a receiver going
through a network of switches.
And I want to ask--
if I send a packet at some point
in time, let's say at time 0,
when does that package
reach the receiver?
That's the delay
for a single packet.
So I just want to explain
to you how to calculate this
or how to measure this.
So let's say that the
packet has a size of L bits.
So what does the
answer depend on?
Let's take an even
simpler example.
Let's say that I have a sender.
I have a receiver.
I have one link between them.
No switches.
And the packet has size L bits.
I send a packet at time 0.
When does the last bit of the
packet show up at the receiver?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good.
So I need to define
this thing here.
Let's say that the bitrate of
this link is c bits per second.
So I have l bits and I have
a link that can send packets
at c bits per second.
Therefore, something here
should be l divided by c second.
That is from the moment I
start shipping these bits,
from the time delay between
when the first bit arrives--
first bit arrives
at the receiver
and the last bit
arrives at the receiver,
that time distance or time
difference is c divided by l--
sorry, l divided by c seconds.
Because I ship these bits.
These bits go back to
back over the link.
If I look at when the
first bit arrives and I
look at when the
last bit arrives,
that time difference
is the spacing--
the time difference between
any two bits showing up
at the receiver is
1 over c, seconds,
because if the link can
send c bits per second,
any two bits are separated
apart by 1 over c seconds.
Therefore, from the time at
which the first bit arrives
to the time at which
the last bit arrives,
that distance is l over c.
That difference is
l over c seconds.
This l over c has a
name associated with it.
This is called the
transmission delay.
Now let's say I want
to send just one bit.
I have to now--
I send a bit at
some point in time.
And that bit shows up
some point in the future,
because it can't
show up immediately.
If it did, we'd probably have
to change the laws of physics
because speed of light is no
longer valid as a finite limit.
So what is the time between
when I send the first bit
and when the first
bit shows up here?
What does that depend on?
Like, let's think I want
to communicate to the moon.
I send one bit of information.
I put it out onto the--
or even one sample.
I put it out on the
radio or whatever.
How long before it
gets to the moon?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Depends on what?
Does it depend on the rate
at which I can communicate?
No.
What does it depend on?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
You guys said it.
What is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Speed, and
the speed of what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's
the speed of light
in that medium, or speed of
whatever the signal you use is.
If it's acoustic, then it's the
speed of sound over the medium.
So it depends on
the distance and it
depends on a speed at which
a signal can propagate
through that
communication medium--
for example, the speed of light.
So the distance is b and the
speed of the communication
medium is, let's say, v.
That thing is called
the propagation delay.
So let me organize this properly
so I'm not confusing everybody
with these different terms.
So so far we've hit
two sources of delay.
The first source of delay,
which I said second,
is the propagation delay.
This is the time it
takes for the first bit
to get to the other side.
It depends on the speed at
which a signal propagates
through the medium and the
distance between sender
and receiver.
So sound travels at one
foot per millisecond,
I think, roughly
something like that.
So if I'm doing acoustic, that
dictates the propagation delay.
The second delay is
the transmission delay,
which depends on this l over c.
The third delay is whatever
processing delays there are.
That, for example, is when
a switch gets a packet,
it has to look at
the packet's header,
figure out the destination,
do something to that.
There's some competition
time that the switches
have to work with.
That delay is called
the processing delay.
This is purely some
sort of computing delay.
And it's usually
very, very small.
And the fourth delay
is the queuing delay,
because it could be that
you get these packets in
and they have to sit
behind in a queue.
And that imposes a
delay in communication.
So that's called
the queuing delay.
And it's usually a very
variable source of delay.
On many networks, these
other delays are constant--
not always, but
generally constant.
The transmission delay may
or may not be constant.
But usually these
are more constant.
The queuing delay is
not a constant delay.
And the actual delays
that you experience
when you click on
a link, there's
lots of reasons why
the website is slow.
But these are a
principle, dominant factor
in many, many cases.
So we'll pick up on this next
week after the quiz two stuff.
You deal with quiz
two and p set 6.
And we'll continue with
multi-hop networks.